Ups, meine Maus geht auf dem anderen Bildschirm nicht, das muss ich fixen, sonst kann ich
Chat nicht angucken.
So, Chat, wo ist der Chat?
Chat ist nicht da, Chat not hot.
Chat geht, Moin, Leute, bisschen später heute, Lautstärke ok so, ähm, ich würd sagen wir
spielen jetzt erstmal 1-2 Runden und dann poste ich überall, dass ich am Start bin,
jetzt bin ich wieder eingespielt, naja, was willst du denn kurz soll ich einspielen, naja,
so ein bisschen, ja jetzt muss ich einspielen, naja komm, also, ich mein es kann nicht jeder
Rechtsklick in den richtigen Intervall drücken, also du brauchst schon so ein gewisser, also
ich muss ganz ehrlich, also jetzt mach mal hier nicht, zieh das mal nicht ins lächerliche,
ja, die jutschen Mercy Plays, so, ich entweite, ich muss ganz schon, CS Mercy lächerlich machen
und nicht mal on sein, das ist schon eine schlimme Kombination, Bun, instant, ich seh
keine Viewer, warum seh ich keine Viewer, dafuck, was ist hier los, jetzt seh ich Viewer,
null Viewer haben wir angeblich, was sich nicht damit deckt, dass im Chat jemand was
schreibt, so, ich glaub jetzt geht alles, moin, Felix, ich wollt grad sagen Felix, nein
es ist Filet, Filet und eigentlich sind die Opossum TS mit dem richtigen 1337 Turbo Icon
anstatt dem Prime Icon, nur die Pros haben das Turbo Icon und ja ich weiß, dass man das
umstellen kann, ein bisschen Samsung ist auch da, moin, wer soll ich sonst noch so online
bei Overwatch, mal schauen, nicht so viel wie es aussieht, der Torb, da guck da, kriegen
jetzt bestimmt wieder Torb und Symmetra Mainz, da war es auf die Tastatur geschüttet, zumindest
nicht in die Tastatur, sondern unten auf die Tastatur, lul, habt ihr eigentlich schon
gelesen, dass es sehr wahrscheinlich nicht Bad Company 3 ist, was als nächstes Battlefield
kommt, was mich enttäuscht ehrlich gesagt, anscheinend Bad Company 3 erstes Jahr danach
und anscheinend kommt wohl stattdessen ein Battlefield im zweiten Weltkrieg, wo ich mal
überhaupt keinen Bock drauf habe, was mich so absolut nicht juckt, ist es on, oh nein,
da ist man eben, ja es ist nur der Saamer, nein das ist ja sehe ich jetzt on, aber ich
Habe ich was drauf geantwortet? Dann habe ich es gesehen, ansonsten habe ich es vielleicht nicht gesehen.
Mich juckt das so überhaupt nicht, ganz ehrlich, es ist mir so egal in Battlefield im zweiten Weltkrieg.
Kannst du noten?
Jo.
720p, klar, immer 720p.
720p hat mehrere Vorteile. Es sieht besser aus, es hat weniger Artefakte.
Weil Twitch plus 6500 MBit zulässt, maximale Bitrate. Mehr geht nicht, äh 6000, nicht 6500, 6000.
Also das ist schon mal nicht viel, und da ist 1080p mit 6 Billionen in der Sekunde nicht drin.
Und es ist sogar einfacher zu encodeen, also es ist eigentlich alle was davon.
Templewächter sagt, der Leaker hat seine Credibility verloren.
Naja, ich meine, er hat ziemlich genau Battlefield 1 geleakt und ich kann ja sein, dass es genauso ist wie er sagt.
Ich finde das klingt eigentlich plausibel, dass DICE Schweden an Battlefield 1 weiterentwickelt und daraus quasi Battlefield 1 zweiter Weltkrieg macht, wie auch immer es dann heißen wird.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass sie es Battlefield 2 nennen, weil dann ist echt, da ist die Kacke am dampfen, dann blickt gar keiner mehr durch.
Ähm, das ist schon logisch, ja, und dass jetzt quasi Dings hier Danger Close oder wie sie heißen, da die Hardline Jungs Bad Company 3 entwickeln.
Und ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen, dass das gar nicht so übel dort aufgehoben ist.
So, ready?
Auf geht's.
Late Night Stream, ja, 1, 2, 3, geht's los.
Heute ist nicht Instant Match.
Was ist da los?
Das Game ist ein bisschen leise, oder?
Boah, ich mach das Game ein bisschen lauter.
Ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Ich pick, ach nee, Deep Defense.
Ups, äh, da pickt eh keiner was mit Schild, ne?
Ich pick mal was mit Schild.
Und jetzt haben wir, oh jetzt haben wir eine Anna Moira Heal Kombi.
Haben wir denn, haben wir denn einen Mercy Main am Start?
Ja, wir haben e ist
Eis
Drei ist drei reiß keine ahnung wie der Typ heißt der ist Mercy Main
Ich habe das Game lauter gemacht es müsste jetzt besser sein
Ich muss es ja auch so abmischen dass es dass ich selbst alles höre in dem game
Da fok rein hart was mit reinhart los
Der hat so ein paar probleme gerade
Ich meine hier
Opie fire strike bei weiß gar nicht wie der geht auf der map der open fire strike
Warum hast du eigentlich ja gehangen ja geht es noch dort also habe ich die rüstung an
Bundeswehr rüstung
Er ist weißt du aus dem kopf wie man das machen konnte dass mit reinhart rückwärts gucken konnte das geht doch jetzt irgendwie
Sagen wir haben wir haben wir hier leute irgendwo stehen an die stehen natürlich nicht hinterm schild
Was der sinn vom schild jetzt nicht ich gehe jetzt ran
Was der sinn vom schild jetzt nicht unbedingt besser macht
Mit der wie konnte ich ihn da vorbei denken
Ich noch tot
Ja das wäre es noch das fehlt reinhart noch
Ein armer le skin das wäre doch mal was
Meurer saugt Meurer saugt an mir
Sniper ich denke ich stelle mich um die ecke die ana steht da halt ziemlich
Meine mann schild ist kaputt
Ich habe gleich ulti, ich habe gleich ulti
Jetzt habe ich nicht mal mal mal ein chat da raus gekriegt
Da wird geschneibert
Schneiber sind wir weg ich bin gleich wieder am start
Leute ihr müsst ihr müsst mal ein bisschen zurück ihr dürft jetzt da nicht sterben
Die scheiß diebe hat uns gerade gekillt
Konnte einfach nicht warten wenn ich mir damage
Ich bin schon da
Gleich, gleich gibts
Gleich gibts chat da
Oh nee
Ich war wieder viel zu aufgespult
Jawoll, huge bomb
Oh, jetzt mach ich richtig auffahren
Dabei hab ich gar nicht gepennt
Da können wir noch mal ran
Scherz
Piss dich Genji
Piss dich Alde
Ich geh mal vor an die Ecke
Naja
Da meurert sich was
Sind vielleicht komplett vollständig
Oder ist noch einer auf dem Rückweg
Perfekt, perfekt, das ist ein perfekter Spot
Oh
Äh
Fuck
Ich brauch Hilfe, ich brauch Hilfe
Ähm, ok, die haben keinen Bock vorzukommen
Ich geh mal in den Voice Chat
Ich hätte auch zurückkommen können
Aber ich versteh ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum
wir nicht ein bisschen vorpushen konnten
Man weiß es nicht
Ich bleib mal vor dir stehen
Ganko
Ganko, ja
Ich geh mal hoch
Ja
Ich hab gleich wieder Shatter am Start
Prost
Die ultimative Flank Action
ist am Start
Weiß nicht so genau
So, jetzt haben wir wieder Shatter am Start
Huge Shatter, huge slam in your face
Einfach spät gemerkt, die anderen
Nee, ich bin doof reingescharrt
Das hat Zeit gekostet
Man Conteste zusammen
und nicht alleine
Willst du nochmal Contest gehen oder?
Nee
Huge
Ich zieh rein
Das war aber auch dumm
Ich mach mal was anderes
Reinhardt funktioniert nicht so richtig
Ich hab da jetzt mit Winston rein
Die haben doch nicht mal ne Mercy
Ach, wir haben auch keine Mercy
Deswegen ist das Match so merkwürdig
McCree, McCree
McCree
McCree dort fährt durch
Wenigstens einer die Bubble Tappen fahren würde
wenn sie da schon steht
Das wär echt nice
Ich brauch Heals
Oh
Erstmal richtig schwach werden
Übrigens die Überforderung des Nodes
Haha
Hanzo
Okay
Geh jetzt links und nimm keinen Raum
Zack eins
Okay
Hanzo ist wieder da
Help, help, heal, heal
Hast auch Hanzo, komm
Hanzo ihn weg
C9
Ich geh jetzt gleich auf Winston
Da oben rein
Gefisstet
Hanzo, jetzt will er es wissen
Das kann er nicht auf sich setzen lassen
Dass der Gegner Hanzo gespielt hat
Er muss jetzt quasi Hanzo spielen
Na gut, der ist, der ist
Das ist ne krasse Kombination
Der Typ ist Reinhardt, Hanzo, Roadhog, Main
Das ist beziehungsweise
Eigentlich ist er Reinhardt, Hanzo, Main
Das ist ne Kombination, die sieht man tatsächlich ziemlich selten
Was hat dieser Lust?
Der Lust kann ruhig wieder D.Va spielen
Wäre Saria nicht die bessere Alternative gewesen
Saria ist halt null mobil
Der Stuhl ist schuld
Nicht das Feuer
Das ist natürlich auch ne gute Erklärung
Wenn er mit den Pfeilen sich trifft, dann mit dem Hammer
Das ist, könnte die Kombination erklären
Wahrscheinlich spielt er immer wieder Hanzo
Sackt übelst, trifft nichts
Und denkt, dass ich komm nach Kamp treff ich
Ja, das kann sein
Guck mal ob hier irgendeine Junkrat trap ist
Nope
Schieben wir schön an die Ecke, schieben und dann gehts
Druff
Ich hüpfe mal raus
Auf die Draesor, die hier irgendwo rumspringt
Push mal weiter, ich geh gleich wieder hoch
Oben ist nix
Na fuck
Ach, da ist doch das Eier, mach Blatt
Die steht alle dahinter, push mal weiter
Ich lasere die, sobald sie rauskommen
Ich seh was denn das
Da passiert ja gar nichts
Ich geh gleich weiter vor
Ist der Reaper, war der Reaper auf dem Dach
Ich hab's zu kurz gesehen
Ja, war er
Mercy
Genji muss den natürlich übertreiben
Ich übertreibs auch grad voll
Äh, warum ist die Ulti nicht raus
Gib ihm, gib ihm
Ich muss wieder rauskommen
Gib ihm weiter, gib ihm noch mehr
Die Mercy oben
Ich bin oben, nicht die andere
Geh beten
Alter, was ist das denn hier für ein Match gerade
Da fuck
Ja
Hast du gesehen, wie schnell ich in Ulti tot war
Der hat mir grad so als ich einmal in den Kopf geschossen
Alter Schwede
Das hat reingehauen
Ja, das hat reingehauen
Kommt man da hoch
Nee
Hinter dir, äh
Reaper
Oh, die Reaperflank
Alter, wieso killt den denn keiner
What the fuck
Echt jetzt
Da ist
Wir haben schon eine Tiefe am Stein
Was ist denn das für ein Game
Ich hab gefühlt nichts gemacht
Wozu mal
Da steht ein McCree
Das ist schon ein Problem
Alter, der Reaper
Ich muss weg
Das war knapp
Noch einmal regroupen, push
Ein easy win
Das war knapp
Noch einmal regroupen, push
Ein easy win
Wir können jetzt einfach mal regroupen, Leute
Come on
Zarya
Oh fuck
Jury
Jetzt aber
Hinter uns ist ein McCree
Kannst du nach hinten springen
Easy
Der Hanzo
Der Hanzo hat gecarried
Sehr spannend
Sehr spannender Play
Ultra spannendes Play of the Game
Er hat zwar schon was gemacht
Aber er hat es nicht gemacht
Der Wahnsinn
Weil so viel Mercy gut ist
Wenn du so hart gefressen bist, dass du keinen Bock mehr hast zu spielen
Ja, linksklicken
Ab und zu mal Kuh
First win of the day
Ich bin mal kurz zwei Minuten weg
Ja, mach das
Ich pause den Krempel jetzt mal auf Twitter
Auf YouTube posten, den ganzen Krempel
Ich hab das letzte Mal gefragt
Und ich hab gesagt, jawoll
Please immer auf YouTube ankündigen
Dann mach ich das jetzt auch mal
Also Max, was ist mit einem Update zu den einzelnen Helden?
Was meinst du genau?
Du meinst ein Video zu jedem Held?
Meinst du das?
Moin Aston015
Achja, die ganzen Follows, die gestern reingekommen sind
Oder vorgestern
Oder wann hab ich zuletzt gestreamt?
Gestern? Vorgestern?
Ich bin verwirrt
Das sieht man gar nicht mehr
Das sieht man auch nicht mehr richtig
Lol
Du hattest am Anfang von Overwatch
Mal jeden Helden kurz angeschnitten
Stimmt, ja ja, hab ich
Ich hab zwei Videos gemacht
Zwei Videos, wo ich zu jedem Held mal 3-4 Minuten was gesagt hab
Wäre mal angebracht bei den ganzen neuen
Ah
Ich glaub, da muss ich erst ein bisschen länger spielen wieder
Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass Overwatch
Kaum einer sehen will bei mir auf dem Channel
Also zumindest
Also man als Hintergrund-Gameplay
Okay, sagt im Endeffekt keiner was
Da kannste ja auch fast alles nehmen, aber
Ist vielleicht mal Schach außen vor gelassen
Oder sowas
Ähm
An den meisten Leuten ging es immer übelst auf den Sack
Wenn ich irgendwas über Overwatch gebracht hab, ich weiß auch nicht warum
Ich werd an 100 plus Soldier Gameplay sehen
Nuller KD
Mit Nuke oder ohne?
Oder Moab?
Ich mach das
Ich mach das erste Overwatch Moab Video
Das ist die Moab
Machst mal ein Video wieder auf deinem Overwatch Channel
Ich bin grad
Komplett ausgelastet
Mit Videos auf meinem Main Channel machen
Und ab und zu mal stremen
Da krieg ich nichts hin
Ich werd mit ein paar
Ich hoffe zumindest
Dass ich demnächst mit ein paar Overwatch Channels was mache
Hauptsächlich
Wahrscheinlich bei denen, weil da die Leute
Sind die Overwatch Content interessiert
Ähm
Mal gucken was
Auf jeden Fall was zu Overwatch liegt
Hexer Nuke
Oh, könnt ihr euch noch da dran erinnern?
Könnt ihr euch noch an dieses komische
Rumgehälte erinnern, wer von wem die Penta
Nuke geklaut hat oder
Was war das nochmal? Ich krieg das gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen
Es hat doch von irgendjemand
Irgendjemand hat Penta Nuke Gameplay nicht
Oder war das Gameplay geklaut und die er
Zuerst Penta Nuke hochgelassen
Das war eigentlich damals
Das war so ein Affenseres ey
Vor allem was für ein Scheiß man sich damals aufgeregt hat
Ich weiß noch der Tio hat irgendwann mal
Den Fabian also den Friseur gebannt
Und das war total
Total hängen geblieben
Eigentlich über die Sachen wo du dich damals
Aufgeregt hast, da kriegt heute kein Hahn mehr
Danach
Nee, das war nicht Rambo Yolo Hater
Das war nicht Rambo
Den gab es auch damals, ja
Ja, das war was
Da hat man sich damals, hat man sich echt
Über Blödsinn aufgeregt, wo du dir heute denkst
So er pfff, who cares
Ich mein heute lohnt es sich ja auch gar nicht
Irgendwie großartig drüber aufzuregen
Wisst ihr was ich, jetzt mal zur Abwechslung
Wisst ihr was ich als guter
Als guten
Naja Trend, es ist kein Trend
Was ich aber als ganz gute Entwicklung auf YouTube empfinde
Zumindest im Englischsprachigen Raum
Im deutschen Raum
Auch ein bisschen, aber ich mein
YouTube Deutschland ist halt voll mit
Ja
Low
Einzel, Gehirn
Content
Im Englischsprachigen Raum
Gibt es sau viele
Science Channels, also jetzt nicht so
Nicht so dieses
Dieses total übertriebene
Nach dem Motto wir zeigen euch jetzt den gleichen Scheiß
Den wir euch immer zeigen, machen aber da ein riesen Tammtamm drum herum
Nee, sondern so wirklich
So Spacetime gibt es da beispielsweise
Als Channel und sowas, finde ich richtig cool
Die sich dann beschäftigen so mit
Was weiß ich, das Universum
Die Galaxie, das Sonnensystem
Science Channel, gibt es total viele im Englischsprachigen Raum
Und die gucken auch viele
Und werden auch viele empfohlen und sowas
Und das ist wirklich richtig guter Content bei vielen
In Deutschland gibt es da auch so ein bisschen was
Aber das finde ich ist eine ganz gute
Entwicklung
Ich mein noch mehr Scheiße braucht man ja auch nicht
Ich mein irgendwann ist ja auch mal die Scheiße
Die jemand konsumieren kann, die man braucht
Gesättigt ja, die verteilt sich
Höchstens noch weiter
Hallo Klarname
Sowas wie kurzgesagten sowas, das kenne ich gar nicht
Little Samsung, ja N24
Dokos sind totaler Müll
Auf N24 läuft gefühlt jeden zweiten Tag
Die größten Flugzeugträger der Welt oder sowas
Zumindest als ich früher noch geguckt habe
Und was ist mit IT Mythen
Sowas
Ja soll ich queueen
Easy
Und was ist mit IT Mythen
Ja mach ich, mach ich auch wieder, ich habe schon ein paar Ideen
Aber ich brauchte halt so vier, fünf Sachen wo ich mich
Was ist denn los, warum geht denn das so schnell
Ja siehst du doch, im anderen Team ist ein Diamond drinne
Jetzt müssen wir testen
Ob man nicht 1500 Abstand machen kann
Zwischen den Spielern
Wahrscheinlich
Kann wer gute
Grind Games empfehlen
Aber erstmal noch eine Frage, suchst du eher einen MMO
Oder sowas wie Diablo 2
Also suchst du jetzt eher was
Mit Open World
Und vielen Leuten unterwegs
Oder suchst du so Diablo
Mäßig Hack and Slay
Hast du Bock
Mit dem Roadtrip ein
Probieren wir es mal
Sonst sind wir sad
Wenn du Bock hast
Wir haben wieder keine Mercy, wenn die Gegner Mercy haben
Ist das quasi schon wieder instant lose
Ich würde dir Mercy picken
Wir haben ja so einen
Wir haben ja den Moira Main
Wie viele Stunden hat er dann
Sieben Stunden und danach Mercy
Viele Leute, naja bei MMO
Auch BDO empfohlen, das ist das Grind Game schlechthin
Aber
Wenn du irgendwas suchst Richtung Diablo 2
Spiel Passive Exile
Das ist das beste Action RPG
Das beste
Diablo Hack and Slay
Like Game
Was es gibt zur Zeit
Also was heißt zur Zeit, das ist es schon seit
1-2 Jahren, 2-3 Jahren
Sogar es gibt es ja schon ein bisschen
Passive Exile ist das beste in der Richtung
Mit Abstand
Oh nein Junkrat
Spam Kacke
Ich hüpfe jetzt direkt rein
Hau doch weg
Ich bin hinten drinnen, ich brauche Help
Musst du wieder auskommen
Wo war es doch mit dir gewesen
Das war es mit mir auch so auf Workbench
Guckt Leute
Und deswegen braucht man eine Mercy
Oh ich hätte mir das aufnehmen sollen über das Dach hüpfen
Okay es war nicht das beste Beispiel
Aber es kann durchaus sein können
Dass die Gegner das jetzt nur halten
Weil sie eine Mercy haben
Ich werde gleich mal hoch aufs Dach hüpfen
Och du Scheiße
Hast du es dir anders überlegt?
Nein
Der Junkrat hat sich das anders überlegt
Fuck ich kann da nicht hoch
Bleib mal von unten, da ist so ein Schäbel bis sie kommen
Entschuldigen den Pack
Chill
Schieben, schieben, schieben
Ich spring jetzt hoch
Der soll schon hüpfen runter, der ist lebensmüde
Nein nein nein Junkrat da falle ich nicht rein auf den Scheiß
Zum Glück hat man dann mal einen Shot der Action
Ich habe gerade das Laufen verkackt, bin nicht mehr hinter die Ecke hingekommen
Was?
Fuck
Lol
Und Tschüss
Und noch einer weg
Ich kick die zu euch
Oh oh ich muss weg
Easy, easy clap
Ok pushen
Das war doch ein nice Winston play
Das war ja mal die easy
Das war ja mal die easieste Runde I can wall die ich je hatte
Das war was, keine Ahnung
Ich glaube die Gegner hatten keinen Bock
Ich gebe zu es war ein schlechtes Beispiel für warum die Gegner gewinnen wenn sie Mercy haben und wir nicht
Aber normalerweise ist das so
Das ist so geil wenn du einfach jemanden wiederbeleben kannst der nicht vom Spawn vorlaufen muss
Ja gut das zweite Checkpoint war ja übel für den arschfülligen Gegner
Das sind die alle wieder runter geschmissen worden
Was willst du denn auf der Presse
Haha
Little samsung skype verwendet auch keiner mehr heutiges Discord
Ist angesagt
Ich weiß gar nicht ob die ähm die etwas jüngeren ob dann auf Snapchat und sowas angesagt ist
Ein Programm wo sich mir das Ding noch nie erschlossen hat wenn ich ehrlich bin
Hast du Preseason OVL geguckt ja alles alle Matches
Skype TeamSpeak das Discord beste
Ich meine es ist eine kacke elektron Java Script Browser im Fenster Anwendung die massig RAM frisst Discord
Aber eines der wenigen Anwendungsfälle wo ich wo ich das okay finde
Will den ganzen Scheiß auch immer neu programmieren
Jawoll
Oh oh oh der Fist der Fist fistet
Links ist der Roadhog drin
Siehst ihr Leute und jetzt wäre die Mercy Gold wert
Unsere Leute recken die natürlich auch so weil anscheinend die Gegner keine Lust haben ordentlich zu spielen
Aber jetzt wäre die Mercy Gold wert gewesen
Jetzt schreckt
Panzer steht an der Eck
Ich bin gleich wieder vorne
Ich kann da wenig dagegen machen gerade
Links links mehr Crew drin
Ich weiß nicht so genau was die machen um ehrlich zu sein
Solche Sachen ja solche Sachen warum machen sie das ist die Frage
Oh nice Hit gleich Ulti am Start 7%
Scheiße dass der geholtet hat Schild kaputt
Was haben die denn
Schon mal der Aff raus
Hat korrekt
Oh nee das war Waste das war Hardcore Waste
Nicht dass wir den gleichen Kack jetzt machen wie die Gegner
Schöpf mal runter ich geh runter ran
Ich weiß einfach so genau machen
Die kommen nicht wirklich vor oder ich geh runter
Der Rock der Rock ist unten noch
Die haben es nicht so lange gehalten
Ich geh drauf
Zu weit gesprungen
All die Zeit ist gut
Ich bleib hinten stehen ich hab kein Bock wieder zu
Ja natürlich
Macht ihr das da gerade
Kann man eigentlich wenn man das ordentlich zielt
Funktioniert ja
Das war ja mega entspannt
Was hältst du von Kryptowährungen
Der wurde deleted
Ich zieh raus
Das versucht jeder ein Stück vom Kuchen abzukriegen
Da bin ich da falsch für
Die machen das einfach
Da bin ich da falsch
Da bin ich da falsch für